bien ce rapport parlementaire publié
hier sur le bilan de l'application de la
loi sapin de une loi adoptée en 2016 sur
la transparence et la lutte contre la
corruption après plusieurs mois de
travaux les parlementaires ont noté que
ce texte avait permis à la france de
rattraper son retard mais pointe du
doigt quelques insuffisances
on en parle tout de suite avec estelle
phare jallet devant l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
estelle bonjour alors c'est un bilan
globalement positif mais des
améliorations sont nécessaires
et oui olivier et même un second souffle
c'est ce qu'indique ce rapport
parlementaire
cette loi présente un progrès
considérable mais la france reste
toujours en retard c'est ce qu'a déclaré
le député lrm raphaël gauvin qui est le
co rapporteur du texte déclarations
faites devant la commission à des lois
de l'assemblée nationale a car la france
reste classée à la 23e place du
classement de transparancy international
il ya tout de même des bons points le
texte salue par exemple la création de
la cj ip la convention judiciaire
d'intérêt public
elle permet par exemple aux entreprises
impliquées dans des faits de corruption
de négocier une amende avec le parquet
sans poursuites sans être déclaration de
culpabilité cette procédure a jusqu'à
présent rapporté plus de 3 milliards
d'euros au trésor public alors
globalement le rapport présente un bilan
est satisfaisant de cette loi dite sapin
de mais préconise tout de même est
d'améliorer certains dispositifs et
justement quels dispositifs doivent être
améliorés estelle
et bien par exemple olivier un
renforcement du rôle de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique en la dotant de pouvoir de
sanction et d' enquêtes le rapport
préconise aussi une refonte des missions
de l'agencé française anti corruption
ainsi qu'un élargissement de son
périmètre d'action elle réalise
actuellement à des contrôles dans les
granges dans les grandes entreprises
son champ d'action à pourrait par
exemple être étendue aux petites
filiales à des groupes étrangers enfin
sur les lanceurs d'alert le rapport et
mais des critiques sur le dispositif mis
en place pour ces derniers qui selon le
texte les expose je cite un risque
financier et juridique considérable
la transposition d'une directive
européenne sur la protection est des
lanceurs d'allèves pourrait venir
renforcer ce dispositif
merci beaucoup à eux seuls pour ces
précisions estelle farges en direct
devant l'assemblée nationale